allez on va la passer aux invités du
soir on va revenir sur l'affaire Pierre
Palmade puisque ça rebondit encore la
drogue les soirées ça senté son avenir
on va on a d'incroyabl révélation à vous
faire en exclusivité dans TPMP petit
récap et Claude fourni l'ancien
producteur de acteur sera là et Michel
Marie arrive on aura les huit
révélations à vous faire sur l'affaire
Palm parce que il y a encore des
révélations merci encore Stéphane Ravier
regarde
merci il y a quasiment un an jour pour
jour Pierre palmat provoqué un grave
accident de la route faisant plusieurs
victimes dont certaines qui gardent de
lourdes séquelles encore aujourd'hui le
traumatisme est psychologique il est
énorme elle est sous antidépresseur sous
anxiollytique un grave accident survenu
après avoir passé des soirées chemsex
des soirées mêlant relations sexuelles
et consommation de drogue son train de
vie lui imposait d'avoir au moins 6000 €
par mois pour acheter sa drogue et
aujourd'hui cette affaire qui a
bouleversé les Français connaitt
d'étonnants rebondissements alors Pierre
Palmade a-t-il replongé aujourd'hui
l'homme est-il désormais libre de ses
mouvements près d'un an après l'accident
retour sur les incroyable révélation de
l'affaire ce soir dans
TPMP voilà bon merci Michel Marie
incroyable il joue
avec il joue ave mod
Daniel tout pourexciter un
mal fa tout
pourexciter nouveau détec dans ans il
est
s merci mich Mar d'être là on vaevenir
sur les révélation et merci à mon ami
Claude Fournier que j'aime merci d'être
là mon Claude merci et puis bonsoir à
tous merci d'être là mon Claude c'est
toujours un bonheur quand je te vois
producteur bien sûr historique de Pierre
Palmade c'était mon producteur aussi
claud four j'avais fait quand j'avais
fait un spectacle c'est lui qui m'a
produit et c'est vrai que ton seul
spectacle mon seul spectacle c'est toi
qui m'a produit tu as perdu énormément
d'argent merci d'être là toi tu as bien
fait de faire avec gâ et R ta gueule ta
gueule mercive Stéphan gâ mon ami J rev
mon ami également alors on va venir sur
laaffire Palmade et on a huit
révélations à vous faire ce soir la
première une des victimes comme vous
l'avez dit comme on l'a dit hier une des
victimes de Pierre Palmade est au plus
mal aujourd'hui hein c'est les huit
questions qu'on se pose au plus mal donc
ce que vous nous avez dit hier Michel et
et Myriam oui oui les la la la la la la
jeune femme qui était enceinte que qui
finissait son 6e mois est au plus mal
elle est sous anxiolitique et
antidépresseur elle n'a pas pu reprendre
le travail elle a encore des blessures
notamment à la jambe et au bras et puis
surtout elle est traumatisée le fait
d'avoir dû accoucher comme ça et d'avoir
vu son bébé elle a dit aux enquêteurs
qu'elle avait même compter les doigts de
de de de sa fille elle est vraiment
traumatisée et elle a du mal à sortir de
chez elle donc elle n'a qu'une envie
c'est que Pierre Palma de aill en prison
euh voilà donc c'est c'est vous avez
suivi l'affaire également claud bien
entendu et Gill oui le père aussi le
conducteur le conducteur va mal aussi il
a été SEP fois opéré euh voilà il a
encore un handicap très lourd et
l'enfant qui avait 6 ans qui a 7 ans
maintenant il porte un corset il y a eu
un choc à la tête il a une immense
cicatrice il a vraiment du mal à se
réinsérer il parle pas il a du mal à
manger c'est très compliqué pour les
trois victimes c'est très très lourd
deuxème question et on va faire de
nombreuses révélations ce soir pierre
palmad a-t-il replongé dans la drogue
oui
alors il a replongé au mois de juin au
mois de juin il a même demandé lui-même
à aller au mois de juillet retourner
dans le service de
de Bordeaux il est resté plusieurs jours
il a il a effectivement avoué d'ailleurs
aux enquêteurs qu'il avait repris de la
A3 MMC la la fameuse drogue pour les
kemsex et que il avait besoin à ce
moment-là de réconfort et que donc il a
replongé c'est l'effet craving je sais
pas si vous savez ce que c'est cet effet
où en fait on est tellement en manque
qu'on est obligé de de reprendre de la
drogue pour se
sentirou vous saviez ça qu' av oui il
l'a reconnu lui-même même et notamment
il a été filmé dans une boîte de nuit à
Bordeaux où il était où il a reconnu à
cette occasion avoironsommer des des
produits stupéfiants vous avez tes
nouvelles Claude non moi j'ai pas de
nouvelles directement avec la famille à
part euh de temps en temps sur Facebook
des petits likes et tout sur mes
messages surtout quand ils sont
personnels et familiaux j'ai la maman de
pierre qui me laisse ran que j'embrasse
très fort aussi la maman pierre qui me
fait des petits likes et qui ça me
touche beaucoup d'ailleurs on va poser
toutes les questions ce soir même les
questions qui dérangent le plus hein je
vous le dis sur cette affaire parce
qu'il y a eu énormément de rumeurs déjà
pierre palmad est-il vraiment
complètement libre de ses mouvements non
non non non il a il a eu un parcours
judiciaire un peu chaotique il a failli
aller en prison il a eu un bracelet
électronique il a été incarcéré sous
bracelet électronique mais à l'hôpital
parce que la justice a préféré le
soigner que de l'enfermer ce qui à mon
avis était pas forcément une mauvaise
idée euh et ensuite le parquet avait
fait appel de la décision du
jugeinstruction parce que le parquet
voulait à tout prix l'embastillé comme
on dit finalement la chambre de
l'accusation n'a pas donné suite et n'a
pas donné droit au parquet ce qui fait
qu'il a été placé sous contrôle
judiciaire il est toujours placé sous
contrôle judiciaire avec quatre
interdictions celle de quitter le
territoire celle de revoir les deux
personnes qui étaient avec lui dans la
voiture au moment de l'accident
évidemment de de conduire un véhicule
automobile et encore une obligation de
soin pour lutter contre ces mauvais
penchants à propos des stupéfi en le
contrôle judiciaire est quand même très
like hein il est libre de ses mouvements
tous les weekends ça lui a quand même
permis de reprendre de la drogue ses
rendez-vous à l'hôpital sont pas
extrêmement réguliers donc quand même
c'est plutôt une situation assez
privilégiée quand vous dites reprendre
de la drogue on on sait qu'il en a pris
une fois il faut peut pas forcément
faire une généralité et il a dit très
honnêtement il a été dire au policiers
qu'il en avait repris et il a euh il
s'est fait réhospitaliser donc mais
quandme oui claud non moi je je voulais
dire pu à chaqueis que je suis venu sur
ce plateau j'ai à chaque fois qu'on
parlait de Palm j'ai aussi fait un
parallèle avec ma vie personnelle bien
sûr et donc euh arrêz de prendre la
drogue c'est facile quand on est enfermé
et qu'on n pas libre de ces mouvements
justement puis moi j'ai fait deux cures
non mais j'entends bien mais c'est pas
propos c'est le propos c'est pour dire
que pas mich Michel non mais le propos
c'est de dire c'est de dire que moi j'ai
fait une cure dans une clinique bobo à
Boulogne que tout le monde connaît
puisquil y a on y on y C avec des
ministres et des des députés et des et
des artistes et des sénateurs
peutêtre et mais mais j'ai j'ai fait 3
mois là-bas c'est vrai c'est quoi une
une ça c'est incroyable c'est ce que
vous nous dites là que c'est une
clinique où il y a que c'est une cl
c'est une clinique entre guillemets
ce qu'on appelle VIP show is c'est genre
ouais c'est tous ceux qui sont drogués
et qui enfin quit si tu veux c'est une
clinique discrète ouison fait
desintoxications là-bas ouais moi je
suis resté 3 mois là-bas ouis et et le
premier jour où je suis ressorti j'ai
recommandé de la drogue ah ouais ça
c'est la première fois et la deuxième
fois
j'étais je finis tout de suite à l'asile
ce qu'on appelait avant l'asile de
Charenton chez les fous j'étais donc à
Saint- maaurice pu c'est à Saint-Maurice
et là je suis resté dans le public mais
dans des conditions drastique et j'ai
plus j'en ai plus plus repris après bah
c'est très bien euh ce que je voulais
dire c'est que rien n'établi aujourd'hui
que Pierre Palmade a repris de la droite
part une foisou bon en tout cas Pierre
Palmade veutil échapper à Pierre Palmade
veut-il échapper à l'homicide
involontaire c'est ce qui se dit alors
pour l'instant ces blessures
involontaires parce que le la mort de de
de cet enfant que que portait cette
femme
Mila n'a pas respirer quand il a été
quand il est sorti du ventre de sa maman
et donc par conséquent il n'a pas
d'existance légale encore n'importe quoi
ça bon non mais c'est c'est comme ça
posez la question je vous réponds et
donc voilà à partir du moment on peut
pas tuer quelqu'un qui n'existe pas bien
sûr euh